fast casual chain Cava has turned
Mediterranean dishes into a nearly $4
billion business but most of its growth
came from an uncommon strategy buying a
competitor quadruple its size and
converting all its locations into
Cabas i' like to say I went to bed
running about 70 restaurants and woke up
running over 250 restaurants the
strategy turned cava into the country's
biggest Mediterranean restaurant chain
leaving many to compare it to where
Chipotle was a decade AO go its success
depends on how long the Mediterranean
diet can remain popular the company says
it's using lots of customer data to
strategize where to open new locations
but now that Caba can no longer rely on
an acquisition to scale up how can it
continue to grow at such an ambitious
Pace growth takes time it's expensive
it's it's variable and I think that's a
little bit of coming down to
reality this is the economics of
Cava Cava has been rapidly expanding for
years cabba really likes the suburbs
they really see potential there and some
of those communities probably don't have
other Mediterranean food options or
readily you know marketed to them
options um that they might seek out we
buil a really robust real estate model
that includes demographic and
psychographic Analysis and we then uh
use mobile analytics to understand where
our guests are coming from where they're
going and then kind of create a DNA of
our guest bace and then heat map that
DNA across the country to then show us
where we have the highest likelihood of
success in 2018 Cava bought Zoe's
Kitchen another chain of fast casual
Mediterranean restaurants for $300
million at the time Zoe's Kitchen had
261 locations compared to cabba's more
than 70 but Zoe's Kitchen was burning
through cash it was a melting Ice Cube
and we didn't want it to turn into a
puddle Zoe's Kitchen shman said had lost
its ident identity serving as a
cautionary tale for cabba I think over
time zo's had lost its focus it had
added many menu items I think the
consumer was kind of confused as to what
the brand really stood for and what
their core competency is versus at Cava
we're really about these modern
Mediterranean flavors 38 ingredients
very simple focused operation most of
the new restaurants kava open from 2019
to 2023 came from converting existing
Zoe's Kitchen locations this meant kavic
could scale faster and at half the cost
of building new restaurants from scratch
when we looked at the Zoe's real estate
portfolio we saw many sites across the
portfolio that we would love as a Caba
site that we felt was really
underperforming its potential so we felt
like this would be a way to rapidly
expand our brand in a part of the
country we were trying to enter into and
we could do it in a much faster way than
if we were trying to Source these deals
one by one Cava converted its last Zoe's
Kitchen in October 2023 which means that
now it has to build new locations from
the ground up Cava is currently in 24
States plus Washington DC and it went
public in June 2023 as it looks to grow
it hopes to capitalize on the rising
popularity of the Mediterranean diet
which it hopes to appeal to a broad
range of customers across the country
right now only 1.4% of us restaurants
primarily serve Mediterranean cuisine in
its last quarterly report cabag group
reported a net income of $6.8 million
with a restaurant level profit margin of
25.1% Cava is now the largest
Mediterranean style restaurant chain in
the country but is it the next Chipotle
Chipotle was really taking Mexican
Nationwide in a very unique way that's
an assembly line style of creating
burritos and bowls and Cava is seeking
to take Mediterranean food Nationwide
with also kind of more of an as line
fast casual style
of service but Chipotle was getting
going when fast casual really was barely
a blip so there was a lot less
competition then cabba has a lot more
competition now whether the restaurant
succeeds May largely depend on whether
customers continue to seek Mediterranean
food Mediterranean has gotten a lot of
good Buzz right it's seen as healthier
it's good for the heart and you know
overall body that said it's still new
Raisa tahini Falafel for a lot of
communities these are still new kinds of
food foods and that's still a question
mark do people want to eat this day in
and day out as opposed to just trying it
as of October 2023 Cava finished
converting all Zoe's Kitchen locations
into cavas but it's told investors that
it will continue growing its number of
locations by at least 15% each year I
think the biggest question is can they
grow in the way that they've said that
they're going to for their for their
investors and do it organically now they
have to open their own sites find their
own sites make sure the sites are good
be able to afford
paying for this real estate and
construction costs and other costs it
plans to open at least three restaurants
in Chicago which will be its first major
foray into the Midwest it's targeting 47
to 50 new restaurants in 2024 with
locations based on a significant amount
of customer data I think restaurants are
a blend of Art and Science and so we
love the science part and understanding
how do we use data to inform our
decisions so it gives us great
visibility into being able to take this
brand to the 26 States not in today and
to go broader and deeper in the 24
States we already currently operate in
but it's a difficult time to be
expanding a fast casual restaurant the
economic slowdown has led to many
restaurants struggling and while chain
establishments are better positioned
than independent ones the market is
saturated despite this cabba is planning
for 15% growth in store numbers next
year if you look at where us-based uh
restaurant chains are now I mean Wing
Stop which is mentioned as the big
growth engine is at something like you
know 11% and I believe Cava is
projecting even more so they have grown
very quickly and they've really promised
more growth at a very high rate and so
investors are going to be looking for
those numbers every
[Music]
year